Now that you know the basic terminology, how does Google know your social circle?
Let me give you a mental model of how our social search works.
Right now, we surface social content that we find in three different ways.
The first way and the biggest in my mind is your public Google profile.
A Google profile is just a place where you can choose to share information about yourself with the world...
...including a list of your different online social services.
For example, you can add a link to your Twitter account,...
...your FriendFeed account, your blog or your Picasa albums.
Bear in mind, it's your choice whether or not to create a Google profile...
...and you can always add or remove any information from it.
Once you've created a Google profile and added links to your various online social services,...
...you've signalled a very clear choice that you're comfortable with the world knowing that information.
Including that you're part of the other social networks you list there.
Based on this opt-in decision, Google can start building a broader social graph.
For example, take the link to my public Twitter account,...
...Google can fetch my Twitter page, just like any web surfer...
...and see that I'm following about a 180 people.
Google will add these 180 people to my social circle.
We also crawl one step further to build out your extended network.
For example, if I'm following my best friend...
...and he's following five different people,...
...Google will add those five people to my extended social circle.
Since it's likely that some of them will be connections of mine as well.